many travelers this will be the first
spring break vacation in over two years
and booking data from travel companies
suggests it will also be one of the
busiest in recent years so where can
last minute planners go and how can they
save travel expert janine tornatory
joins us with what to expect at spring
break hot spots plus unexpected ideas
that are both affordable and less
crowded hello how are you
it's great great to be here with you
great to have you first let's talk about
where it's going to be busy what are the
top destinations for travel this spring
break
well it's a lot of the usual suspects
that you would expect you've got orlando
miami cancun phoenix and las vegas you
are back on the list so i think a lot of
people might be looking to head out as
everyone heads to you and for travelers
who have not made spring break plans yet
do you have any recommendations for
affordable destinations
yeah there are still some great spots
out there i'll start with hawaii
actually you know a lot of people may
think this might be too expensive right
now i actually found flights from las
vegas into honolulu 400
about the thing that you would pay to go
to some of those hot spots in florida um
i really love the area around waikiki
because there's so much hotel
availability even some of the really
beautiful iconic properties like the
moana surf rider one of those westin
resorts and you know look it's a great
destination if you either want to hang
in waikiki on the beach or do something
a little more adventurous so hawaii
should still be on your list if you're
thinking tropical i also if you want
something a little closer to home
portland oregon flights under 150 round
trip and the reason i like portland is
because you can have that great uh kind
of city escape in portland they have
beautiful japanese gardens they have a
really fun food truck scene lots to do
there but then you can either choose
from day trips up into the mountains or
to the coast so you can kind of have a
kind of fun dual
vacation they are great properties with
availability right downtown like the
portland marriott and then i also want
to mention atlanta so if you're looking
for something fun with the families
atlanta flights under 200 round trips so
much to do with the families in the city
nice mild weather you have the college
football hall of fame the botanic
gardens the aquarium there's actually
three national parks right around
atlanta
it's a great city of neighborhoods if
you're looking for something a little
luxurious stay in buckhead you have the
jw marriott there that has butler
service afternoon tea in their piazza
pool so
lots to do there and really affordable
still now i know this may be asking for
too much but are there still ways to
actually save this late in the game
yeah that's a great question a few
things that you should consider number
one is with flight most people actually
leave on saturdays and sundays for
spring break their kids get out of
school on friday and that's when they
head out so if you can be flexible and
travel monday through thursday you're
really going to find better availability
and some decent prices to some of these
off markets for your flight um also like
we're doing now kind of think like a
contrarian if everyone's going to the
hot spots where can you go so instead of
beach think about desert destinations
right look at some of these big cities
that aren't going to be into their high
season until summer so that's really
kind of a way to save when you're
looking for
places to go this late in the game wow
such great advice great destinations
thank you so much for your expertise
janine we really appreciate it kendall
i'm going to send it back to you